I realize guys do we get the
notifications I think we did just got it
yeah I just did - okay no I I have to
subscribe to myself so I get the
notification I gotta move my skull - oh
okay so how is everybody doing today
fantastic very tired but very good very
good yeah it's one of those days right
cuz it's getting a darker so soon and
all that kind of starts getting cold
even down here in Niagara Falls so
everybody is kind of getting a little
bit under the weather but here at Rand
cafe we never stop this train has no
brakes yeah welcome everybody if you're
watching we're here for the third
episode of Rand cafe what we're going to
be talking about the best and the worst
anime characters and joining us today we
have a man who another's makkal heme
ackles not makkal not remember that how
does it how's it going see what is on
Mac we also have returning this week
Brin from Brenda's fandoms some people
have one or two fandoms Brin has all the
fandom sabra all the fandoms
every phantom every anime fandom mostly
whoo and we have our boy breaks from
all-day anime when some people watch
anime two or three hours a day he
watches it all day long what up Briggs
it's very true all day every day
what is everyone excited to be here nice
nice yeah so this is gonna be a fun time
we're gonna be discussing the best and
worst anime characters and this I want
to just want to say what up to everybody
in the chat how are you guys doing are
you doing well I should probably pull up
the stream so I could see the chat
there's vector Maximus by the way he
helped inspire this week's topic because
he said that we should talk about heroes
and anti-heroes
and then I thought that's a good idea
but let's broaden in a bit so let's talk
about the best and the worst of all
types of heroes but yeah it's really
cool that well connector and yeah I was
thinking for this stream we talked about
the best and worst and we can also talk
about the subcategories so like the
creepiest the coolest the most badass
the scariest whatever you guys want to
talk about let's do it anybody wanna
start I think it's a cool topic just
because like I think a lot of people
underestimate how important characters
are to a story like if a store if the
characters aren't interesting or like
you're attached to them the story just
isn't the same you could have an awesome
story but if I don't care about the
characters
it doesn't like I don't care about the
story as much so I'm pretty looking for
I'm looking forward to this topic very
good point Briggs very good point we
have joining us already
one master what's up one master house
Finland and this time of night like 11
p.m. I believe Vaughn Maru is here with
us we have ladoga we I saw vector I
don't know if rebus here yeah Travis
here creep Ellen what's up mmm-hmm
crazily is fabulous so yeah we got a lot
of good people on the chat some real
awesome people's real awesome people's
so let's let's get started let's get
started
Mack you want to start with you yeah oh
well okay well right off the bed you
just say something just saying yeah
shout suckers the word get that out and
I mean I think we all know why at this
point like memes won't die and I think
that speaks wonders if them if you're so
bad that you spawn a meme that doesn't
die like you're you're you're doing it
right like you're you're bad person and
polar opposite like best I don't even
know all I was thinking about was shot
occur for like the last five minutes so
I don't know FMA or wise who did you say
is best if we know who's worse anyway
Emily Edie Edwards on that for me
I think Mustang is one of my favorite
characters in FM a Mustangs cool
especially like Brotherhood Mustang
because if you just rest
awesome every time like yeah that's cool
yeah I like I like an effing male like
both of the brothers and I I really like
Olivia Mira Armstrong I just think she's
such a badass and strong leader and
doesn't take any crap I like her I
didn't like like kind of side characters
so you know I really like her but by the
way I watched Brotherhood so in case
there's any confusion I mean I'm a
Brotherhood guy so you're one of those I
mean I I prefer Brotherhood to you don't
worry
um yeah I'm pretty indifferent I like
Brotherhood's ending better but I think
people should watch the beginning of the
first one because they go a little bit
slower and like really introduce the
characters a little bit better thank you
like they kind of assume that you watch
the first one in Brotherhood they're
like yeah let's just skip the beginning
let's rush it exactly like I almost
stopped watching Brotherhood right off
the bat because like owls voice was
different it was going through like a
million things at once it's like wait a
minute wait a minute slow down he was
dead by like episode 7 this time and
then I loved it and but looking like it
gets better obviously but then you're
right it's cuz of the assumption that
you've seen the first one and everyone's
seen the first one so you still enjoy it
either way but I I usually tell people
watch the first like it'd probably have
to be like close to a hundred episodes
like nine the episodes if they didn't
rush the beginning things that he added
so much more content towards the end
ain't nobody got time for that
well yeah you have all day all day it's
true what yes so vector has asked a good
question he says do are we talking about
worst in the sense of like worst evil or
worse in a sense of badly designed and
developed I guess we could talk about
both for me I was also thinking about
like most hated but we could talk and
also badly like design like really
crybaby characters that's what I was
thinking I was thinking badly design and
I saw the topic yeah we can do both I
like for me in terms of the most-hated
I the first two people I thought of are
shocker and Nina from Kogi us of course
your mom like
shout Tucker's daughter Nina like what's
wrong with yes
Nina [ __ ] drove her poor father crazy
the diggeth Akita guys true very true
yeah yeah just like your poorly designed
run-of-the-mill awesome guy that's
awesome but nobody knows why he's so
awesome but what we like we really
talked about that a lot in the last
female like he's badass for no reason
and girls like him for no reason I think
we need a little bit of like backstory
or like something influenced that you
know exactly actually even worse and so
Darla I think the supporting characters
that were they're not given enough time
so I don't care what's happening to them
there were some tragic stuff that
happened I'm like I'm not gonna remember
their names yeah that was my that was my
point that I made to Mack in one of the
previous streams because he liked the
last kind of arc where the girl that's
introduced a few episodes earlier ends
up being sick from AIDS in real life
like some kind of super aids like a new
version of it and he thought and he
thought that was like a very like
emotional part but to me it's like be so
rushed it like it looked like they were
gonna do another arc with like the
Nordic mythology and then they all of a
sudden like switched it to Austin Ozark
with those new friends and to me I
didn't get to the point where actually
caring about those characters like yeah
I thought it was sad of course but like
I didn't get to the point of like oh my
god I really care about this character
yeah yeah I mean like when that daughter
was introduced and like why are you here
this is where the story goes downhill
when you have this small child together
it doesn't make sense anyway for me
that's when stored online went downhill
yeah the first few episodes were so
strong as it's like didn't develop the
characters enough they they did a lot of
time skips as well so it's like I wasn't
attached to people you know like that
daughter thing like I did not see that
coming it was kind of pretty irrelevant
yeah yeah that was just like moy like
it's like more fanservice like oh she's
so cute
that's exactly what the show it's like
they're just trying to appeal to all the
things like Oh badass me
like male character that's good at video
games let's get all the gamers in there
that's like let's put some cute girls in
let's make it like get some cute girls
in and then I think this added all these
things but they didn't like develop it
and do it properly I saw I felt like to
kill him a gamer but no well yeah I
totally I totally like the premise and
like if you said the first few episodes
where it's like when they're just like
in that world they're thrown in there
it's like you you if you die you die in
real life kind of thing like I thought
that was really interesting or cool
premise but then like yeah like as it
moves like the character developments
and things like that doesn't hold up
yeah and by the way go ahead how'd you
guys feel about the characters in attack
on titan eren just is always angry yeah
I mean your family's dead it sucks but
like he's angry and everything and I
can't I don't know I can't make us is
cool
don't get me wrong make us is the
coolest she's like one of my favorites
like ever but other than that like I
couldn't really get into what's his name
like anyone else like Arian coconuts
Armand that's but ya know I couldn't
really couldn't do it yeah and I and
that you guys did play simultaneously
was very good at describing the show for
me and a Mac you mentioned like how you
liked the premise and I was me for
attack on Titan like I went in I'm like
this premise is so cool like humans not
on the top of the food chain type of
thing but then I just didn't care about
the characters enough so one day died
and like the side characters died it
wasn't as impactful and I'm like oh I
don't need it like that's one less name
to remember
yeah like I also agree with the
characters that I'm talkin I'm like I
was everyone was so into attack on Titan
it was like people are still really into
it I didn't get the appeal I'm like I
thought it was okay I you know I watch
the show I will continue to watch it
they make more seasons but it was like
one thing I hate about it is that yeah I
don't really care about Arman like I
like me cuss up too but like they keep
they also the character stuff is one
thing and then also the fact that they
keep on dragging the it outta me reminds
me
the original Dragon Ball Z like it took
them like four episodes for downlink
dust to settle after Aaron becomes like
a spoiler alert afternoon becomes like
the thing for the first time right like
they're like human arm and are like
talking for like three episodes as the
dust is settling and the soldiers are
waiting to kill them like I was like why
are you dragging this out so much and
then the twist at the end - like they
dragged it out so much like I already
figured it out like five episodes
earlier I was like all mmhmm yeah yeah I
I could not stand Armin like I tried to
get behind him I was like okay you know
he's supposed to be like the smart one
who's gonna solve all the problems but
I'm like you're such a weenie
like you just need to stop it especially
after he saw while Aaron get eaten like
I mean yes that's traumatizing but like
move on okay he's eaten as far as we
knew at that point like I just couldn't
get behind him I just yeah I know I
didn't like the character is when that
weenie was kinda like the only guy I
kind of worked yes Goldmember says that
like attack of time was okay but it was
way over height yeah and I feel like the
exact same way like I thought it was
fine what people hyped it up so much
before I watched it I thought I was
gonna come in and watch a new code geass
or I don't know like full metal
alchemist or something and I was just
like no it's just okay show and the
funny thing about Armin is he always
reminds me of Armin van Buuren is like
this trance artists like electronic
music artists and he when he was younger
he had like long blond hair like that -
and his name is obviously Armin right so
that every time I see how it is like
it's little Armin van Buuren only Armin
in the show was a trance DJ that would
be amazing
I probably would probably wouldn't like
Linnaean see that's that's the type of
like care gives me want it crazy
over-the-top yeah by the way I love
trance music I'm a big fan of trance
music
Armin and all those guys very cool
trance and anime is a good combination
by the way a lot of envies that I like
trance and anime it's like it works
yeah I have our own trick go ahead bring
I'll just they have a trance dance party
up in here that's the next best Red Cafe
yeah that's okay figure out how to I
like music to the stream we'll see we
can figure it out
I know if we can't like just like an
hour of straight fist bump just left
amazing I'd be down let's make it Evan
yep it's fist bumps and caffeine they're
good it's like the perfect combo read me
rose talked about this before you were
probably there Mac I'm not sure which
stream it was but we talked about how
much we both hate Suzaku from court
Geass as a character mm-hmm not because
he's evil necessarily but because we
just hated him as a character in his
motivation so I was wondering if anybody
in the chat or any of you guys had your
opinions on Suzaku because the reason I
hate him is because of his reasoning
like his whole oh I'm gonna fight the
system make the system better from the
inside by helping all these people
essentially commit genocide against my
own nation like Britannia is right so
he's well aware that they're doing these
horrible things they even order him to
execute hostages and then conveniently
he doesn't have to but he had the or he
got the order right so he knows they're
doing all these horrible things and this
is first season like let's say firstly
because in the second season after youth
is death we can say that okay maybe he's
not thinking straight that kind of stuff
but before all that people are calling
him out it's like you killed your own
father because you didn't want war we
pretend you want to just surrender like
this traitor you are because you want
people to die then you're letting them
all you're letting the Britannia pnes
kill all your people and you're
assisting them actively and acting like
you're doing itself right just like how
dare you like how like I hate him I hate
him so much
yeah I was not a family there I feel
like they were like code yes was trying
to do the whole like light and L thing
like he's like two different
perspectives on justice but it ended up
just all of everyone hating Suzaku like
I don't know to pronounce his name well
that's essentially what ended up
happening
mmm-hmm what about you Bryn yeah I
haven't watched code yes so yeah what I
haven't so yep I agree I think you
definitely got all objects that
especially was 7/3 coming up yes season
three so now I can well see that's the
thing now I know cuz it's suppose this
great ending but like now I know that
there's a third season so it's like what
anyways that was that that was last rat
case rat cafes discussion sure but I
have some more bad like um bad guys like
bad bad like good bad guys that makes
this yes best villains yeah cuz that's
the other category did I'd like to talk
about two villains in terms like not
necessarily a bad character just like uh
you won't character villain but like a
very well developed or like a cool
villain mm-hmm yeah on on my list is
Griffith from berserk was definitely a
good bad guy like I hate him so much
but yet like man that writer who I don't
know who's the author who wrote but man
it's a good bad dude I attempt if I can
remember the author's name this is a
little demon yeah an in-depth video on
it I'm sure I would remember it but yeah
Griffith and on flipside guts for great
character but that's for later when you
said guts my first thought was the dog
from kill the kill and I know that's not
what you're talking about yeah okay I
also thought of the dog from kill kill
God not alone that as long as it's not
just me that's that's okay GTR says
Mello is the worst and I from Death Note
and I feel like a lot of people hate
Mello and I thought that was like
universal that people hate mellow but
then like I also saw actually on YouTube
that there's a lot of people like mellow
was a hero man he sacrificed himself so
they could get Kira he's a hero
oh yeah I don't know like what do you
guys think about Melo
No yeah I don't think it was alright it
just like you can't compare to the El
and light like battle it was just
downhill from there regardless of how
good or bad the characters were even
even more than Melo that I I mean I feel
nothing towards him but I do feel some
hatred towards Misa because I just can't
stand her
I cannot stand her at all same without
feel like trying to think of characters
I hate and like top three yeah that's
nice is pretty like crazy she's like a
yonder red but light is too smart to let
her like mess with him but she's totally
like insane I feel like some people like
to meet so I think too many people like
Mesa yeah yeah but to each their own
right some people like Mesa some people
put ketchup in their craft dinners the
world's not a nice place I put ketchup
on my eggs all the time that's okay
that's okay I'm fine with that if you
want to put ketchup on your eggs you go
for it but ketchup on Katy we we've got
problems we'll catch up with Grote's
partial I mean mm-hmm
like about it okay that's you know what
I'll let that slide but as soon as a
piece of macaroni and or extra cheese
comes onto that mac and cheese it's
talking about best and worst food
actually liked mellow which is yeah
interesting yeah like like in the Death
Note second season they're talking about
how near and Mello together had to
combine forces to defeat here because on
their own they weren't as good as well
but then together they managed to do it
but yeah I don't know like I'm not a
huge fan of theirs but I thought they
were okay that we're interesting
characters obviously compared to L
they're kind of like a letdown but the
one thing I like about near is that he
plays with toys too will concentrate and
I believe that because I can
do like cuz uh like when I'm for example
if I'm like writing a short story or
like something fiction I like to use
toys like act out the scenes and like to
focus before I actually write it so I
could relate to him yeah like I didn't
mind mellow that much I hated me so like
10 times more and she was there for like
the entire surely a good portion of it
near was cool he was alright
it just like Canella it's not the same
it's just a little bit of a letdown like
you said out of that yeah and speaking
of L I definitely had him down as one of
the best characters and what most
memorable one of the best what did you
guys think yep
oh yeah the entire battle between Ellen
Light was like fantastic yeah what the
best like a cat and mouse kind of thing
like they're just equal it's like who's
gonna be better this time who's gonna
win this time
cuz they're both at the same level
anyways so yeah I like L yeah good point
and they're both kind of like very
memorable characters right like light is
like a super genius who kind of like
just kind of the power goes to his head
and he becomes like this crazy mad
genius kind of thing and then L is also
like a mad genius but in a different way
right and then he has all his quirks and
things like that which I feel like
really make these guys very memorable I
wonder why they decided to kill L off
like I don't know who thought that was a
good idea out of it they were like okay
we gotta like with it maybe they didn't
know how well like you would be or maybe
they just thought oh let's let's just
surprise everyone like I don't know but
yeah yeah I actually didn't mind the
ending of death no like I wasn't a fan
of like a lot of like the second half
that much but the actual overall ending
I actually really liked but it would
have been 10 times better if L was the
one who like finished it off
well disappointed by the ending yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay now that I mean the
right the ride throughout the rest of
the show was good enough to make me like
in enjoy it as a whole so like still
like death no it's just the ending I was
like yeah I like the ending as in like
the last 25 but the actual last episode
I kind of liked how they did it oh yeah
no Alice last 25 was fine but yeah the
ending was just want to say what up to
Jonathan Essex cyanide blizzard and
Maria editing slower in the chat what's
up guys how's it going and yeah in terms
of the ending of death though like it's
like it's a fitting end because to me
it's like light is like a Greek tragic
hero about because in Greek plays and
things like that they're often the the
hubris
so the pride of the hero and of course
in Shakespearean plays were influenced
by Greek tragedies is his downfall so
he's like a great character he's like
you know strong he's smart and all this
kind of stuff
and then he has that one fatal flaw that
brings him down and like with Macbeth or
you know it in like Agamemnon in the
Greek plays so I feel like would
definitely definitely follow that
pattern and so his hubris he's thinking
that he's the best and that he you know
he will rule the world he will be a god
so like he totally takes it too far and
that is his downfall in the end so yeah
I didn't mind getting of course if light
didn't take it so far if he had more
like conscience I feel like he could
have done a lot of good with that but
yeah I was satisfied it just I agree
with what you said well more or less
satisfied with the last episode I'm
surprised you haven't talked about any
girl agon I don't know yeah you're like
I'm putting it off because obviously
coming up is my favorite character of
all so I'm trying to like get all you
guys to get some let's talk again before
I'm just like so calm any minutes right
like what I was thinking with the stream
and like oh that's the UNESCO with
you're in there god I'm surprised it
didn't but yeah that's cool yeah we'll
get there good
Africa yes some of my favorite were
definitely also spike Spiegel from
Cowboy Bebop
if you haven't watch that show watch it
for sure
Sinbad from McGee I don't know if any of
you guys to watch smoggy yeah if I Simba
that character he's pretty cool as an
old country and stuff like I feel like
yeah that's what I want I want my own
country I mean I can relate yeah lelouch
all as well I really like the Louvre and
the Elric brothers for sure
what about female characters though I
had some female graders on here but you
guys haven't mentioned on many I'm the
only one that mentioned Mira Armstrong
so what are your favorite female
characters oh four favorite okay hello
sorry yeah your favorite you think
they're the best like I assumed you
don't think like your favorite kickers
would be because you think are the best
yeah um I haven't watched the fête
series but I hear everyone says great
things about Sabre and apparently she's
great but I've seen it really I really
like sago except for an unlimited blade
works I feel like they took this awesome
character that was so badass in the
first like face day night and was really
badass in fate/zero and was a really
cool character and I feel like she just
didn't live up to what an unlimited
blade works like she just didn't do as I
think she was got her ass kicked way too
many times and like when I was looking
back at the series I'm like she didn't
actually win any battles like she just
didn't contribute as much right a little
bit like upset about that cuz like I
love her yeah I have o for females my
favorite females
Yona from you know the dawn but like for
character development wise like a plus
man it's good stuff
if you've watched it ya know what
actually so I've got a lot a lot of
female ones actually Michael on you know
we want to say anything before I start
talking about the whole bunch I had
they're all gonna make FM yeah I mean I
think I think my favorite would probably
have to go to like holo from spice wolf
she's just cool like she's just like
master mrs. master obsess either what
you can take your pick but she is she's
just cool oh no I just smile every time
I'd like every time I watched bison wolf
you smile all the way through because
the whole oh she's awesome your roommate
just walked right by okay yeah two of
them yeah that happens all the time with
Mac you'll see a whole bunch of people
walking like just like it's a journey a
journey it's a journey
he's the North Bay so sometimes you'll
see like a moose the odd caribou I can't
think of anyone so you could start
ranting Oh what are your characters no
I'm gonna end up being a feminist here
but I definitely have a lot of female
characters I like I had I like Nagisa
from Clannad because she's just like
such a innocent character that's also
like has a difficult life but she pushes
through it and struggles to make friends
it's something that's like like you get
really kind of root for her
I had Haruhi from her visa zooming and
she's she's like the ops she's kind of
like I've told Sumeria but she's also
hilarious in so many ways so she's kind
of like has an attitude and does crazy
stuff but because of that like hilarious
stuff she does she's lovable I had of
course Colin from Code Geass I love her
because she she's like a nationalist and
she's willing to fight for her country
and stuff and I really respect that
political stuff not nothing else there's
no other reason why I like her you'll
call from Gurren Lagann of course I
think she's also very badass very
entertaining there's a lot of badass you
know captures like Revie from Black
Lagoon yes I had to jump in there yes I
couldn't think of anyone
back down my dentures didn't ya rabbee
and then also c2 from Cody yes is also
quite interesting so yeah I think
there's a lot of cool female characters
out there I definitely agree they do
exist in the highly populated male
protagonists mm-hmm like there's a
deafness a lot of solid female
characters for sure like adam ak who
would you say is your who do you think
the coolest act like my like in my
opinion the coolest anime character
you've already mentioned him I want to
get your opinion who do you think the
coolest anime character is so yeah it's
the depends how you define cool right
because in terms of best like I'll talk
about an obvious I think calm you know
is the best character because he's such
he's such a like inspirational character
he's like it's like it there's a
philosophy behind it when he's like do
the impossible kick reason to the curve
it's like actually saying like don't
limit yourself but what people tell you
is possible don't limit yourself but
what people tell you is realistic like
thing beyond that is very it's
interesting because there's a parallels
in like the Bible and Christian
teachings where they're like you have to
have faith you have to believe in things
and if you do that thing miracles will
happen kind of thing and I like that way
of thinking that thinking outside the
box because so often today we're told
you know well you know you gotta be
realistic you gotta work this job
because you make this much money or you
gotta you know you don't spend too much
time on YouTube videos and livestreams
go and do something else right but I
feel like yeah common is just so
inspirational like obviously he's badass
he kicks ass and then he also has this
like he pushes you he inspires you and
so that whole philosophy I try to always
remember that in life when I'm having
doubts or I'm having you know people are
telling me oh you gotta be realistic you
gotta calm down things like that I
always try to actually remember so the
fact that I think oh communist a way to
like develop myself and improve myself
and inspire myself I feel like that's
what makes the greatest character the
fact that it's not just an anime you
think about I mean your wife you
implement his lessons in your life so
that's why
yeah he's definitely like one of the
most motivational characters I could
think of like if any other character
said the stuff that Communist said I
think it would come off like cheesy but
like you just tell like the way like I
guess he's like takes himself like he
believes every word he's saying and like
he believes that you could do whatever
you like whatever you set your mind to
like he's just like a really
motivational character his one-liners
are on another level I love him yeah
exactly like some people would be like
oh like let's make following things that
but he is so like he backs his talk up
with actions like he's ready to go he's
ready to fight like so you people mock
him and at first whenever someone meets
and remember in the show they mock and
all right this guy's he lost his mind
but then they all end up respecting him
because he's sold you know ready to
sacrifice himself for his friends ready
to do what it takes he never lets
anything bring him down you never he's
never gets negative like he for an
instant when he finds out his father is
dead for an instant that brings him down
and he starts thinking about like he
sees the skeleton and he's like oh man I
could die like this could all be for
nothing and then he's like screw that
and then he just goes into it even
harder and he's just like he's such a
great man yeah I think it's a well
designed character as well like kind of
like I feel like Gurren Lagann is very
over-the-top and crazy and I like won
like I guess the main character or one
of the main characters kind like
embodies what the show is all about
communist is so over the top intrigues
and it's like kinda embodies what it
Gurren Lagann is all about yeah and
that's what it makes you keep an open
mind because some people would say this
is unrealistic this isn't you know I
can't believe I can't buy into this yeah
those are the people are kind of limited
by this idea of things have to be
realistic like who says what realistic
is like why not just be open-minded and
just let it flow kind of thing right
that's the beauty of anime it's not
absolutely no need to realism the
idealism right anime like obviously just
realist anime and existential sedima
things that but like what I love about
anime is that idealism that you know the
fantasy actually it moves you be honest
like their artistic new in a romanticism
it's like we're not just looking at the
real
we're looking at what the world could be
we're getting it to strive to believe
and then that's striving and that
believing will lead to action that's
actually gonna make these things
possible in the real world so again if
you only think about what's possible now
you're never gonna see beyond the
horizon to what could be possible one
day
exactly yeah I was just wait I thought
that was how the stream we're gonna
start off with that calm you know
reading characters like do you know act
a character with seven episode get a
seven episode Showtime essentially sorry
for the spoilers but you might have
impact the character that's only shown
for seven episodes could have and he
impacts the rest of the series even when
he's not there exactly is a great
character a real man never dies even
what he's killed right kameena always
comes back like people's knowing like
they think back what would calm you know
do what would calm you know do what you
know calm you know the common 'voice in
their heads drives them for the rest so
it's like so long like just wow Mac and
grim any thoughts on why I'm right ya
know coming is good I liked gurren
lagaan but I I like to Yoko too cuz I'm
like or Gaddafi ously into spoilers
already so were past that
but I liked how she became a
schoolteacher I really like that about
her totally unexpected but like it made
me respect her like she wasn't just this
big all boob gun girl that we you know I
liked her for that but I was like oh you
have more to you than just like yeah
yeah good point
I like what the people that made her
like I know they're triggered it weren't
trigger back that with other trigger
studio and they also made killer kill
and like I like how they like poke fun
and like the established things in anime
saw the fanservice they have a lot of
fanservice but they do it in like a
creative way so with yoga right like
she's they do a lot of yoga fencer is
but at the same time she's always being
a total badass at the same time she's
very much independent like she's not
like reliant on anyone she's like
interesting character and then
kill a kill they have like in-your-face
fanservice but then they have like this
justification for it because the clothes
the less you have it the better because
it doesn't take you over like it doesn't
start controlling you because of the
kind of the life fibers so it's like
they devise an actual way to do fanswer
it's because they have to do it because
otherwise like the life fibers control
them kind of things so I thought I was
really interesting and then like nudist
beach like yes just the funniest thing
like I have I love that like the guy
from nudist beach the main guy's
reminiscence will calm you down a little
bit like you can't repeat comment on by
that guy's pretty cool yeah I'ma be
honest I dropped killer kill after three
episodes
yeah I know I have to go back and give
it a chance got a lot of times when I
drop a show like I end up liking you
when i rewatch it but a lot of times
it's just kind of like I have to wait
for the next week I was walking a while
was varying and iced wasn't that into it
and I never got back to watching the
next episode and when I forget like when
I go like two or three weeks without
watching a show it's gone same I get you
know it's worth going back to like if
you finish it it's like I had a ball the
entire time watching it but I kind of
get [ __ ] like I do the same thing we're
all start an anime and be watching it
and forget about it for like a few weeks
and that it's just it's gone and worth
the worth the watch if you get a chance
to get gems yeah I definitely gotta add
it to my never-ending list look at the
watcher because if you like Gurren
Lagann which is a over the top yeah
killer kill because it's all it's
obviously over the top right from the
get-go it's crazy but it's also very it
gets to be philosophical it gets to be
interesting with the whole Hawaii fiber
stuff so yeah definitely gonna watch
like my brother wasn't that into it he
watched it through the end but I keep
getting into didn't he wasn't that into
it but like I see a lot of philosophy
behind and I see a lot of parallels with
Gurren Lagann in terms of style and all
that stuff so I would definitely
recommend killa kill mother of the year
yes so someone mentioned I know who was
it was one master maybe it was my master
into Chad they were saying every harem
protagonist is badly developed because
they're just like your average small got
a crybaby and everyone loves them but I
guess that depends on what kind of harm
it is because I feel like you know
there's good harem anime like Clannad
because it's technically a harm because
it's the main guy that has a lot of love
interests but he he is an interesting
character he's an interesting past he
has a interesting history interesting
character development right where but
then like I feel like with like edgy
anime like the ones they're designed
just for edgy like the characters are
completely worthless like they're just
like yeah completely like a it's like a
fantasy it's like you can be a complete
like crybaby withdrawn type of person
and you can still have all these girls
love you right yeah it's definitely
fulfilment like you could input yourself
for that character yeah you definitely
get a couple of those every season for
sure I have another topic well another
anime with good and bad characters in my
opinion um what did you guys think about
re0 did was there any characters that
you loved or hated I mean REM was
obviously best we'll just get that away
right now okay good but I I don't know
Subaru just kind of pissed me off the
entire time like he just kept screwing
things up but at the same time I kind of
got it I don't know it's weird dude it's
hard to explain but that's mm-hmm he was
weird in the the crazy the crazy dude
with the like kooky biting himself and
stuff like the messed up guy he oh yeah
yeah really creeped me out but like he
was well done like a good job yeah yeah
those guys I'm pretty like I like mixed
feeling for it Subaru like I liked him
as a character but like Maxell you kind
of upset me sometimes like if he was a
little bit
more intelligent with his powers I feel
like I would like them even more because
I'd have been a good aspect I feel like
now he was all he had going for him was
his drive to like and I guess like save
his waifu I don't know I even know like
why you had all this Drive for but like
yeah it's like this huge drive to like
get what you want to done type of thing
and I like I liked him of the character
and I wanted him to succeed however you
feel a little bit more like intelligent
with it I think I would like them a bit
more
mm-hmm okay good you guys echo my
feelings because I put Subaru with like
a question mark under a good character
because story wise he got there like I
mean those flashbacks like the whole
plot was good and like his development
was great but he was just an idiot at
the beginning and still maybe remained
an idiot at the end but something that
still bothers me is Amelia because
obviously REM is the best girl I should
not be the best girl right okay thank
you I was I was a hundred percent team
Amelia at the Starling I was like yeah I
know she's awesome
oh yeah and then ah not just I think I
think everyone got really really really
really really salty at that episode the
whole I love them Elia episode like I
was so mad oh man I still I think I'm
still a little bit team Amelia I she
wasn't given enough time like REM got a
lot of more like I love REM so much I
wanted it like I want to be team REM the
byth like Amelia has potential like
she's still low-key waifu 2016 wasn't a
thing i'd agree with you a hundred
percent like she's yeah great way food
material but yeah actually
yet scenery 0 but you can't say anything
people who haven't seen code geass but
um all the means about 3-0 I know the
memes and I will watch it for sure but I
prefer Nissan to super bubble say that
right now and I will say that in terms
of the waifu stuff yeah you get the joke
in terms of the waifu stuff i feel like
just because you know a certain girl
the main characters best girl doesn't
mean that she can't be your best girl
like obviously in code geass colin is my
best girl but Lelouch is best girls see
- and that's okay true that's very true
it's just like it's like callin God
enough time and has enough reason for
her to be best girl like she fought for
what she believed in while Emilia it's
like oh she has all the potential to be
best girl just like it just the show
didn't give it to her they gave it all
over em they gave it all to them except
they still made Subaru for Emilia loud a
little bit mad yeah so would you say
that you're just saying another thing
all good points guys another thing I was
saying about the creepiest scariest
anime characters because some of the I
think the creepiest i'ma characters I've
ever seen in my life is from Black
Lagoon those twins Riggs we talked about
that last time
the two of you seen Black Lagoon oh Mack
and I haven't seen it again oh yeah so
it's it's yeah so you have to see it but
it's like it's basically these two twins
children who are orphans never trained
to be assassins but they're like sole
innocent yet bloodthirsty looking and
they they also like one is a girl and
one is a guy but then they like switch
and like cuz it's a wig so then they
like switch and then do one the other
one there's a girl and the other one is
the guy and you're like who are they
really guys or girls and then they like
also make out with each other
I did not see that coming with Black
Lagoon me the way it started like you
don't see like these twins that are into
each other that are like vampire I got
even freaking no where the hell did I
came from when you go you're just like a
normal badass series with people with
guns and [ __ ] like just a cool badass
series and then it kinda gets a bit
darker but yeah so um Mac and
brenn since you guys haven't seen
blocker who and what are some of the
creepiest characters in your opinion um
I was saying in the comments that uh he
so guys one of my my top favorite like
he's so weird and creepy but it's like
oh he's so cool at rounder oh yeah oh
yeah the clown god yes
he's creepy but a plus is that booty
though
so so it's all good on that list and Dan
Mara was saying juzu el from Tokyo ghoul
definitely creepy definitely weird but I
think I liked him because he was creepy
and weird like he was kind of off the
wacko scale I kind of like that's my
feelings warty so I like I like him
because he's creepy and weird yeah yeah
he's definitely cool he's dressed like a
Venetian like Piazza from like an
Italian opera and yet he still makes it
cool so that's cool
one master mentioned-- Lucy from elfin
lead and I really like like she is such
an interesting and elfin Lee is a really
gory anime so it's not for everyone but
it's such an entertainment because she
is a character where she like murders
all these innocent people and yet she
does it because the whole life but she
has a special special abilities that her
whole life she was like hunted and
experimented on and tortured and
attacked and bullied so it's like you at
the same time as you're like she's doing
these horrible things you also like feel
bad for her and relate to her so it's
like it's really interesting the way
they do that I think that's a big
achievement from the animators to make
you still feel something for a character
that you know has done bad things and
yet maybe not because but done bad
things but maybe not a bad person just
you know life has made her that so true
I
and actually seen Delfin lead yet
unfortunately if you could take Gore
definitely watch it yeah I watched the
first two episodes not even a week ago
and I'm already like it's yeah it should
be wash I need to finish it if you're
into gore and stuff like that bezerk for
those good characters of guts and grills
good stuff but also very gory so got to
deafen job there for me for one of the
most like badass characters yeah yeah
like the other person I wanted to
mention someone someone mentioned Shinji
in the chat and yeah
Ellen Gillian is overall a great anime
interesting concept a lot of
philosophical and like political stuff
in there which I like so I like the
anime but Shinji was such a frustrating
character to me and same thing with that
Renton guy from America 7 like you're
such crybabies like such crybabies like
you have to like hold their hand through
everything and they're just like look
this is me doing these primary
characters every single they really need
a dose of communist communist Amon who
often has like shinji tendencies but
then he has calm you know was just like
I'm gonna punch her in the face now and
then you gotta stop acting like that and
I'm gonna make you grin toasty and then
you're gonna and then he's like thank
you coming I understand do you think
that's a proper development like he had
someone who can make up made him into
the person he was by the end of the show
he started off as not like crybaby
crybaby but by the end of the show he
was like a man he was like he's kind of
filled communist shoes yeah it's very
fulfilling right like it you feel like
fulfilled you feel satisfied when that
happened you see that progression but
with like Shinji like there
some progress but not much it's very
like push and pull and like with the guy
from America 7 all yea-ah crybabies just
yeah it's like anytime you made any sort
of development you kind of just like the
next thing that happened you went right
back exactly yeah just just oh my father
doesn't love me yeah other scary
characters I had I don't know if you
guys have seen Bukka no no I've told my
list though the guy on the train dear
lad Russell is like he's the bad guy
like there's a guy called the Vino who
is the guy with like the blood all over
him I had him as one of the coolest
characters yeah he was cool but the
other guy lab drew so he was like a
villain like he wasn't insane like he
was just like killing people right left
and right he definitely was back and I
had a lot of cool characters in it oh
yeah absolutely it's like it's that's
what it's known for it so I feel like
they they should probably done more with
that a they're like you had a longer
because they introduced a lot of
characters at the same time and yet
they're all pretty cool like they do a
good job like I often when you have like
a character dump like a whole bunch of
characters and please don't don't
mention you what what I know you want to
mention brakes you know you know a
certain independent project but um yep
slow but yeah they did a good job I
think we'd box I know it's very
impressive job anything else anyone
wanted to add I feel like I'm talking
too much I'm just saying a chat but I
dislike crybaby care because when you
day to your crybaby impression I had
like flashbacks of like all the
characters ever in every anime that had
that exact reaction I was like oh like
the rage and that like frustration that
came with it like the one that I thought
of um was calm EAGA kill our main
character I don't even remember his name
but the guy it's like Oh everyone's
dying around me I'm like well you join
an assassin group so what did you expect
about that before you join them anyways
but all the flashbacks crybaby
characters have a hard time with unless
they get better which sometimes they do
sometimes they pretend that they get
better but they don't actually so yeah I
agree I'm not a fan of cranberry
characters but if they do develop
anything I think it's a good character
cuz they have so much room but a lot of
times they never leave that role and
that's horrible
yeah yeah like in very limited doses but
I guess it's also because I can't relate
to cry babies because I try not to be a
crybaby in my life right kind of like I
feel like I'm beyond that point so I
then when they do it I'm just like
that's not what I would do so I like to
be able to like relate here to be like
yeah that's that's cool I understand him
but if I'm like if they're doing some of
the opposite of what I think this should
be done that it's very frustrating for
me to like respect them and to kind of
hang on for the ride and like I only got
through eight episodes of Tokyo ghoul
before I gave up what the main guy was a
big crybaby to guys like holy crap yeah
main kid from Claymore especially the
dub if you watch the dumb anymore yes I
like Todd have a oh my yeah it was
really bad the worst Matthew you dropped
Kenichi right yeah no I didn't I didn't
really drop it like I had started it I
watched like first two episodes I'm like
alright I can get behind this and then I
I just kind of forgot sure he pulled in
like a like yo I feel like yeah a lot of
people don't like the fact that Kenny G
is a crybaby character he really is and
I'm that kind of annoyed me but when it
came down to it like it's one of my
favorite show it is my favorite show of
all time when it came down to it it's
like that cry-baby this completely
transformed anytime like [ __ ] got real
and it was time for him to man up and
like that's what made me love the
character so much it was like it was
annoying when he was training like why a
name but like when it came down to it he
manned up and that's what I liked about
him yeah
yeah Latika is saying something about
Tokyo ghoul being a bot I'm not sure
Olivia you gotta clarify that for me in
the comments but yeah so I definitely
think that the crybaby stuff is a little
bit out of control lately with
protagonist much yeah people stay so I
guess some people maybe they feel like
they are having issues in their lives
and they would like react that way stand
there like oh look this person at first
he's like me but then he progresses and
then he does all these amazing things
maybe I could do that too but I don't
know if sometimes they just don't make
that progress quick enough although the
guy from Claymore did get that kiss I
actually watched that recently was that
in your top 10 kiss scenes on a Mac like
that like one of the first videos on
your channel
it was then uh goes that who made those
videos yes true he made those videos but
yeah yesterday guy who watches
everyone's first videos yeah I love
doing that I love going back and like
seeing where people began started from
the bottom hour my first video a video
is a piece of trash yeah now if we go
look go find it oh look it up I came in
here me the audio so that terms of
funniest characters do you guys have any
opinions like some I had was Hari mah
from school Rumble but I think you guys
haven't seen that he has some really
funny scenes I had a the aakhirah guy
from Eden of the East I don't know if
anyone's watched Eden of the East
he's pretty hilarious and then I also
had of course Cohen chioma or an image
which we talked about him on the last
friend I thought I didn't want him yeah
anybody else have any funniest
characters hmm I had one and it totally
left oh sorry in the in the comments the
guy he gets punched in the balls by one
punch man oh this is the song funny
yes yes yes that was pretty funny that
was like a funny moment but that show
had some definitely some good moments
like do it like he's so intense like I'm
a ninja I'm good on ya like like that's
all this like preparation that's so much
it's so much like maybe fun like the
Naruto stuff like where it's like they
do all this like training and then they
can like yeah ackie late wind and things
like that all it's got stuff and then
one punch man it's like at that point
every guy which is like the app pretend
that people paused story go about go
ahead Bryn cuz it was like the way they
delivered it was like slow and it's like
oh we have some really good executions
there was at the enemy with one punch
man absolutely they just like like the
animation like how they like focus on
certain things like as they lead up to
it like they make like they'll do like a
lead up that's like Sol epic and then
it'll end up being like just like what
gotta like a letdown
but in a fun way I'm having trouble
thinking of funny characters this is
horrible
yo hey soo najara is where it said and
I'll leave it at that
yes those who no no yeah he is good I
will give you that Sunohara his pretty
hilarious not not like my top funniest
characters but he's of the same I think
I think he won from Haruhi is pretty
funny and Haruhi herself is pretty funny
yeah
Harvey's funny but she also gets under
my skin
just cuz she's so loud like I'm guessing
he probably watched it in Japanese of
course I understand I Washington in
English cuz like everyone was watching
it in English and she's so Wow
so loud all day every day and I just the
anime all that there you go there you go
you did you make her he is that you
make the show I just I just want to give
a quick shout-out to movement rider
because everyone's mentioning him in the
chat and yeah he tries so hard Moomin
rider baby green transportation someone
said maybe Mellie Otis but that just
disappeared I don't know where who said
it
he's pretty honey he is a funny guy I
agree malleolus is millio does this
hilarious ayah o malley Odin sürmeli
Otis yeah I think he's hilarious you
know some really funny like pervy stuff
but it's hilarious
in the context mm-hmm oh he knows
pretty funny character Onizuka we were
talking about like Hoenn coma and like
old anime lasts or like old on me last
week whatever Onizuka is a pretty funny
character like I love him yeah Mackey go
ahead yeah that show actually at first
it was like so over to talk crazy in
terms of like him like jumping off
buildings and something I was like
almost like felt like I can't get into
this like what is going on here but then
like if you actually get into it give it
a chance like he does a lot of like
hilarious stuff and also I got you the
life lesson stop so I definitely really
all around like it's just really funny
and then has like morals and stuff it's
cool yeah just that intro drivers hai
like yeah I'm actually like rewashing
yeah like I'm almost done in like a week
oh no how many episodes there and during
exam season so that's pretty horrible I
started the next day after scream after
we started talking about like great
teacher onizuka last week and I'm almost
done I'd like three or four episodes
left pretty bad yeah these guys I'm
guessing haven't seen great teacher
onizuka I don't think so I think I have
alright thank you oh yeah I like it
would but yeah I've watched like two or
three episodes yeah it's kind of hard to
get into it's a little bit like no it's
a little bit weird the first like
episode or two like a little bit of
pervy [ __ ] happening like once you get
into it I stat stop watching it like
that's what I'm once the stream is over
those yeah so there's I there are some
really cool funny characters that I like
I think yeah one punch man is just a
treasure trove like funny interactions
like obviously Saitama himself is
hilarious
Janice is funny too because of his like
interactions with sites on us so yeah
many other best worst kind of characters
that you guys like other cool villains
for example that I can think of are
vicious from Cowboy Bebop
yeah Johan Leibert from monster Johann
kind of [ __ ] up like he's like he's a
good character yeah like a good bad yeah
exactly
a good bad character I have character
that to put it nicely that should go and
die and just know don't like him I'm the
in erase the mother of the daughter
don't know name but she she just go
somewhere somewhere not here cuz I can't
yet what will say spoilers if they say
more so just no one master says
makishima show go from Psychopaths yeah
that's a he's a cool villain like he's
crazy and evil but like he has like a
rationale for it like he's saying he
wants to destroy that like oppressive
society by just like shocking it to wake
up
so obviously you could never approve his
message but you can kind of sympathize
with this goal so again that's I think
the best characters are when they
they're able to like make them evil but
then you still sympathize you're not
just like okay well this character I
just wanted to die is the worst human
being you're just like yeah he should
definitely die is horrible but that like
some of the thought he says makes sense
or something or like you can understand
them because their background like would
elephant leave yeah those are some of my
favorite themes in anime like whether
the good guy is really a bad guy or like
the bad guys really a good guy
definitely Mac
Shema is one of those that he could be
the good guy but he disguised as the
villain hmm things to think about
yeah you should actually watch Code
Geass because of that because it's a lot
of it is like the political stuff and
it's like do you have you know do you
have to become as bad as the bad guys in
order to win a war against them right
like because right there fighting dirty
so does that mean you have to fight
dirty they kill civilians so does that
mean that you have to kill Sony's and
then are you really any better than them
or are you doing it for a just cause so
it's okay so like there's a lot of that
in quotes yeah so definitely recommend
it yeah that's all the stuff I had in my
notes I don't know I thought also cast
her from fate/zero was a cool scary
character like he's insane he's based on
some guy who used like murdered children
and like historical character and that's
pretty badass
from fate/zero as well yeah Gilgamesh
yeah he's a cool guy like he's not like
I go yeah he's not a psycho I'm just
like he's a cool character I hadn't
thought about him good point
he's like a cool like he just wants
power and he will destroy anyone who
doesn't have it like yeah that's also
interesting when people have different
moral compasses so it's a your moral
compass might be I don't want to hurt
anyone innocent but his moral compass
might be I just want all the power
because only a strong will survive only
the strong deserve to survive an
election alright like his outlook like
yeah exactly what like exactly what
you're saying I win this strong deserve
does it survive also the way he looks at
things because like everyone's kind of
fight for the holy grail right and he's
like I don't even want it I'm the king
of King vibe and everything I already
like everything that I would ever desire
in this world belongs to me I am the
king of Cali the way he holds himself
like is unreal he is we have other Kings
like we have Alexander the Great as like
savor what we have like algún of the
greatest rider we have Sabre under more
blood who the hell she is and we have
always like great historical beings but
the way he like holds himself on a
higher level than them because he's
Gilgamesh the king of kings like he
really plays a good role yeah in faith
stay night unlimited blade works which I
watched recently his whole thing is like
you need to kill people the two are weak
because otherwise you're gonna be left
with a world with just a bunch of
weaklings and then they might all be
wiped out by like a plague or a war or
something like you need to the strongest
must survive otherwise you will have a
world that's like going to die off so
again that's something I would agree
with what something guy flying is
actually interesting there's a logic
behind it yeah one weekend we're gonna
be probably wrapping it up soon cuz I
have to do some non anime stuff but I
wanted to ask anybody in the chat if you
have any ideas for next week's topic and
whether any of you guys had some ideas
for next week's topic you Mac like Mac
stuff stop singing and give us ideas
what about best singing anime what's
maybe that was my idea I was just
rolling into it I suggested like long
anime vs. short anime but like I agree
it's not like enough for a discussion
especially since I know like I'm not
sure it will Brin by no Mac and Anna Mac
haven't seen too many long-running
series I don't know like how do you oh
yeah I want to ask you this Bren do you
watch one piece cuz like no one in the
this fan cafe and watches one piece no
you're all alone
so sad Christ appears some people get a
guest to like watches one piece like a
madman yeah and it'll just be it'll just
be like you know it's so later like the
when they went what's his name like
Solan Solan black star have the moment
they're running at each other they go I
could have racked it about one piece
today yeah I tried I try to avoid it
because I thought this was like a very
character-driven throw like I cannot
decide who's my favorite character could
just so many that I love so much
it really drives a story for 800
episodes you know ooh
cosmic potato had an idea says anime
openings I'd be down for there's a lot
of those they exist we could do you'd
like combine all of our small topics
together and take one big episode like
music and anime is an interesting topic
because it's like openings and like the
music because I feel like with like for
example Jun Maya does work like he just
plays the music and I'm already I cry
it's not just like what's happening it's
also the music you just like so thank
you guys for coming out again thank you
everybody in the chat thank you
Bryn Briggs and magma and let's do the
whole thing where you guys again say who
you are and what you do let's start with
you brain because you weren't here last
week yeah so I am Bryn from Bryn's
fandoms that's what you can find me on
youtube and like mostly Twitter I have
other ones but it's all out friends
fandoms if you look me up and I do anime
reviews and discussions on my channel a
lot of anime discussion and topics so if
you want to subscribe to Prince pandas
that's where you can find me yo check
out bridge he's got all the fandoms and
her content is awesome so check her out
and let's go to Briggs what's up
everyone I am Briggs you guys already
know from the YouTube channel all-day
anime I do a lot of facts and
informative videos like top ten facts
like very interesting like it's
interesting stuff you wouldn't already
know about characters in series and like
it's kind of like fulfilling to learn
these things that you've never knew
about like a character they like they've
watched for so long and I'm trying to
implement some like not vlogs but like
something where you guys get the know to
me a little bit that's why I like doing
live streams and stuff but yeah come
check me out yeah definitely check him
out he's pretty good guy we've gotten to
know him and he's pretty nice guy like
he's the only guy that watches one piece
but woo yeah you guys can expect one
piece Hunter hunter and like
what else do I do I do things I can't
think of the other show Oh seven deadly
sins there we go yeah
good show all things he's a Briggs is a
GILF under fanboy isn't oh yeah okay
let's go back oh not all nuts you just
call me all night now but I'm Mac I'm
mostly on Twitch mostly streaming on
Twitch but I do make some youtube stuff
and it's mostly just half-ass sarcastic
stuff but it does exist it does include
anime so I mean if you like anime which
I'm assuming you do cuz you're here
watching a rant about an anime you can
check that out and maybe maybe enjoy it
we'll see we'll see
yeah definitely check Mac out we collab
with him all the time he's a great guy
all of these guys are great guys like I
always said when I feature someone on
this on Ranke face because I love their
content and I think they're great so
check that out the links are in the
description Briggs cue for the outro
thanks again everybody for coming and
until next time see you space cowboys
bang